dr fred thank you for being with us this
is horrible news
what was your reaction when you first
heard how did you find out that your
friend ryan had been shot
my first reaction was just i i
just started crying i mean it was just
unbelievable i could barely i was shake
i started to shake
one of my very good friends in la called
me to say
did you hear about ryan i'm like what
are you talking about
and and then as soon as i hung up the
phone i looked at the footage and i
could
not believe it it was frightening to see
all that blood and just know that it was
my friend my really good friend that was
sitting there
as i'm talking to you i'm getting i'm
chilling up and like
it's just so sad so sad
so you've tried to reach out and you've
not heard anything from him not heard
about his condition
no and i've reached out to a bunch of
our mutual friends as well
um and his mother and i i cannot i
cannot get to them
um and i also called his phone
knowing it was probably in evidence but
uh i figured i'd try it anyway but i
can't get in touch with him and i don't
think they've released the hospital
because otherwise i'd call the hospital
so that's a doctor i'd call him and
insist getting the news
but i don't think at least the hospital
is there any
message that you want to give him that
you're hoping to get to him
yeah and just like ryan we love you
remington loves you
all of the dogs love you please please
please
pull through this
oh my gosh i'm so sorry this is i i
i can't imagine um what this must be
like for you
yeah how are you doing good i mean yeah
i mean i just
can't believe that this is what the
world has become it's really sad
would this really be they're trying to
steal the dogs and resell them no
they're stealing the dogs
they knew they were hurt you don't steal
dogs there's plenty of frenchies around
i mean i mean are they expensive yes but
you know you don't steal a dog because
you can resell them i mean
they they sold them because they knew it
was hers do you think that he was trying
to protect the dogs
is that why he got in the line of fire
he absolutely was trying to protect
those dogs
i mean absolutely he would literally lay
down his life for any one of our dogs
and i certainly hope that that was not
the case this time
brian you will make it
you